are you surprised that almost $300,000
worth of sponsorships fled after this
announcement she did say it was a drug
she'd been on for a year for medical
reasons people are really divided on
this the thing you have to understand is
that Maria Sharapova is a brand
juggernaut she has been the highest paid
female athlete now for about eleven
years and a lot of that money has to do
with her brand power and with her
ability to sell things her contract with
Nike is about is worth about seventy
million dollars over the course of eight
years so there is a strong financial
incentive that ties these companies to
her and there also may be some incentive
for them to back away if in fact you
know she is banned from tennis they did
jump fast so right I feel like we've had
bigger scandals recently where the
benefit of the doubt has been allowed
for a few days I think that there this
was a very very swift response I was
also a little bit surprised by that at
the same time I think there's more heat
on sponsors these days to be responsible
and to be responsive when athletes that
they align themselves with admit to
something as serious as this is Janet
what's the cost
let mean it's crude but you know that's
what we do what's the cost to Sharapova
give me the figures here
well the first most immediate cost is
that she has to give her money back from
that she won at the Australian Open she
went about three hundred thousand
dollars for advancing to the
quarterfinals at the Australian Open
after that the value of her sponsorships
is much much greater than that she makes
about 80 percent of her money about
twenty three million dollars last year
in sponsorships and so it's unclear how
much of that she'll forfeit but it will
probably be a good it'll probably be a
good portion can she come back from this
is that it's on the endorsements front I
think it has to do with how long her ban
from tennis is she's 28 she's had
injuries so if in fact she is punished
with a four-year ban which is possible
it would be very unlikely for her I
think
to come back at 30 to her own brown
sugar povo will it take a hit I think
that's hard to say I think that's hard
to say it is sort of ironic that it's a
candy brand and I I don't I I can't say
I'll have to wait and see there's a
review underway anyway and there will be
a decision at some point when do we
expect the decision
I think it's unclear I know that she
would like to play in the Rio Olympics
and if she but if she is banned and that
ban is upheld she won't be able to play